let's start with the most absurd
question but i've read you write some
fascinating stuff about it so uh let's
go there
are we living in a simulation what
difference does it make bucks
i mean i'm serious what difference
because if we are
living in a simulation it raises the
question
how real does something have to be in
stimulation for
it to be sufficiently immersive for us
humans
but i mean even in principle how could
we ever know if we were in one
right a perfect simulation by definition
is something that's indistinguishable
from the real thing but we didn't say
anything about perfect it could be
no no that's that's right well if it was
an imperfect simulation if we could hack
it
you know find a bug in it then that
would be one thing right if
if this was like the matrix and there
was a way for me to
you know do flying kung fu moves or
something by hacking the simulation
well then you know we would have to
cross that bridge when we came to it
wouldn't we right i mean at that point
you know it's it's uh hard to see the
difference between that
and just uh uh what people would
ordinarily refer to as a world with
miracles
you know uh what about from a different
perspective thinking about the universe
as a computation
like a program running at a computer
that's kind of a neighboring concept
it is it is an interesting and
reasonably well-defined question to ask
is the world computable you know does
the world satisfy
what we would call and say yes the uh
the church touring thesis
yeah that is you know uh could we take
any physical system
and simulate it to uh you know any
desired precision by a touring machine
you know given the appropriate input
data
right and so far i think the indications
are pretty strong that
our world does seem to satisfy the
church-touring thesis
uh at least if it doesn't then we
haven't yet discovered why
not uh but now does that mean that our
universe is a simulation
well you know that word seems to suggest
that there is some other
larger universe in which it is running
right right
and the problem there is that if the
simulation is perfect
then we're never going to be able to get
any direct evidence
about that other universe you know we
will only be able to see
uh the effects of the computation that
is running in this universe
well let's imagine an analogy let's
imagine a pc a personal computer a
computer
is it possible with the advent of
artificial intelligence
for the computer to look outside of
itself
to see to understand its creator i mean
that's a simple is that is that a
ridiculous
connection well i mean with the
computers that we actually have
i mean first of all uh we we all know
that uh humans have done an imperfect
job
of you know enforcing the abstraction
boundaries of computers
right like you may try to confine some
program to a playpen
but you know as soon as there's one uh
uh
memory allocation error in in the c
program
then the program has gotten out of that
play pen and it can do whatever it wants
right this is how most hacks work you
know
viruses and worms and exploits and you
know you would have to imagine that an
ai would be able to discover something
like that
now you know of course if we could
actually discover
some exploit of reality itself
then you know then this whole i mean we
we we
then in some sense we we wouldn't have
to philosophize about this
right this would no longer be a
metaphysical conversation
but that's the question is what is what
would that hack look like
yeah well i i have no idea i mean uh uh
peter shore uh you know the well you
know very famous uh person in quantum
computing of course has a joked
that uh maybe the reason why we haven't
yet you know integrated general
relativity in quantum mechanics
is that you know the part of the
universe that depends on both of them
was that what was actually left
unspecified and if we ever tried to do
an experiment
uh involving the singularity of a black
hole or something like that
then you know the universe would just uh
generate an overflow error
or something right yeah we would just
crash the universe
now um you know the the the universe you
know has seemed to hold up pretty well
for you know 14 billion years right so
you know my uh you know uh
occam's razor kind of guess has to be
that you know it will continue to hold
up you know that the fact that we don't
know the laws of physics
governing some phenomenon is not a
strong sign
that probing that phenomenon is going to
crash the universe
right but you know of course i could be
wrong
you